hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the third round
of the ftx crypto cup it is pragnanda vs
hans chess speaks for itself neman and
uh well a lot has happened in this match
so far this is game four of the match uh
the match started by hans winning uh
then prog retaliated with the white
pieces in the same variation uh they
play in a game four but it's interesting
that uh in the in game two that prog one
where he retaliated uh all the action in
the game was on the queen side where in
this game all the action is on the king
side but from the exact same opening so
that's uh
really really wild
and game three of course ended in a draw
so if this game ends in a draw they go
into tie breaks if it doesn't then
whoever wins wins the match so let's
dive straight into it uh it is one of
those games that uh out of nowhere you
know
the entire board just uh explodes with
action so prague has the white pieces
and they basically repeat game two that
prog one we have d4 knight to f6 we have
c4 e6 knight to c3 offering uh hans the
opportunity to play the names of indian
defenses prague is a big fan of the
nimzo himself but like in game two uh
neiman goes for the
uh for the queen's game we decline the
d5 we have c cap for c captures and
bishop to g5 now so the exchange
variation c6 strengthening the d5 pawn
e3 and bishop to f5 made possible uh due
to the exchange uh on d5 and now prague
goes after the bishop we have queen to
f3 attacks the bishop bishop to g6 and
now
we have a queen trade bishop captures
queen captures queen captures uh and now
g captures on f6 and in game two that
we've discussed prague went for h4 but
here he plays knight to f3 which are the
two ways basically of uh treating this
position both are aimed at uh going
after the light squad bishop next that
probably will play knight h4 and harass
the bishop a little bit but not really
you never want to capture this bishop as
it's not a great bishop you want to play
knight h4 f4 f5 and maybe try and trap
the bishop so here knight to d7 knight
to h4 and knight to b6 now we have pawn
to f4 now preparing f5 but this has all
been played before so of course hans
knows how to treat this with f5
the bishop is now
basically a pawn but at some point
either white will capture which is good
for black or white will play knight to
f3 to try and re-maneuver the knight to
the e5 where you will play f6 uh denied
the knight e5 and g5 squares and shifted
the bishop over to f7 so that's how you
bring the bishop back to life we have
bishop to d3 and now the uh tricky
knights to see c4 attacking e3 and b2
and now you kind of have to capture on
c4 so bishop captures and d captures on
c4 so similar to what happened in game
two
uh we have a bishops against knight so
the knight pair of prague versus the
bishop pair of hans with king to f2 and
now there is one game in the database
where bishop the seven was played from
the 2017 individual european
championship between lupulesco and
zedlock uh but here that lupulesco won
but here we have queen side castles and
it is now as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
prague goes about this with pawn to a4
yeah you don't want to allow b5 to
cement the c4 pawn now c4 pawn is a
target and you have this position where
white will always be better yes black
has the bishop pair so it's uh very very
hard to evaluate this you you know you
want to say white will always be better
because you have a double c pawn and a
double def pawn but the bishop pair if
the bishop player comes alive uh you
know you might even give up a few of
those pawns and
it's going to be a tricky position to
play so bishop to e7 attacks the knight
knight to f3 and now what we've
discussed f6 denying the knight uh whoa
not that e5 and g5 squares and the
bishop will now be shifted over to f7
maybe to help out with the defense of
the c for pawn so knight h4 bishop to b
for now uh for the moment you don't
worry about this because you actually
want white to capture this so bishop to
b4
rook h to c1 now preparing to move the
knight and put pressure on the c4 pawn
and the rook h to e8 and here frog has
to decide uh you you could capture on g6
for example captures captures and then
play knight to d1 and there's no way you
can defend the c4 pawn uh so that's one
way to go about it but uh prague decides
to keep uh everything in the game and uh
he he wants to win the f uh five pawn uh
instead so he goes knight to d1 right
away attacks the c4 pawn and now says
okay you keep your bishops you can
defend with uh bishop to f7 but then i'm
gonna take the f5 pawn and this is it
again it's incredibly difficult to
evaluate this because it's the bishop
pair
so bishop to f7 captures the f5 pawn and
now pawn the c5 uh hans uh gets rid of
the other doubled uh pawn as well and
now his bishop pair will come alive so
knight h6 attacking the bishop but now
of course hans does not want to give it
away bishop to e6 pawn to f5 bishop to
d5 and now it'd be great if you had e4
and d5 but you don't so knight to c3 now
you are uh
putting again pressure on this bishop so
bishop to c6 and now rook back to d1 we
have captures captures and now bishop to
a5 rook to d2 uh preparing to double up
on the d-file or maybe bring the other
rook into the game via the e1 square and
now bishop to b6 so if you remember from
that position where the bishops weren't
all that impressive uh now the bishop
player has most certainly come alive
uh rook a to d1 prog doubles up on the d
file and bishop to e4 now uh very very
uh nicely done uh going after this
bishop the d3 idea and then if the rooks
will not be able to defend the d4 pawn
then you will just win it uh without any
problem so here uh hunts is basically
saying uh you have to capture this
bishop and prague believes him he plays
knight captors on e4 i will show just
for fun uh what happens if knight to f7
is played as this kind of wins the game
for white it's a very very tricky move
the rook now is hanging and you don't
really have a a good way of
dealing with this for example rook d7
attacks the knight now we're gonna play
rook to e2 and when you play rook
captures on f7 rook captures an e4 with
your d4 pawn always defended and now for
example rook captures knight captures
with the threat of knight to d6 with
this beautiful fork rook to d7 let's say
but now king e3 we defend the pawn
and you have this position where uh
white is up upon and this is in fact a
winning position for white uh there is
uh isn't all that much you can do and
also the f6 pawn is hanging so uh it's
uh
impossible to hold it's just g4 h for g5
at the position basically plays itself
so instead after bishop to e4 prague
believes hans he plays knight captures
on e4 rook captures an e4 and now king
to f3 chasing away the rook but now also
the d for pawn falls so rook captures
rook captures we have rook captures and
now of course rook the c1 you cannot
trade here because if you trade captures
captures the b2 pawn will fall there's
no way for you to defend it and then
hans gets this beautiful past c pawn so
instead rook to c1 by prague and now
comes rook to d3 check king to e4 and
now rook to d for king f3 rook to d3
check and prague could continue uh hans
would most uh likely agree to a
three-fold repetition but prague has the
white pieces and before going into tie
breaks he will try of course
to push this further so keen g4 rook d2
now attacks the b2 and the g2 pawns and
rook captures on c4 with check king d7
now comes king to h3
defending g2 but giving up the b2 pawn
so rook captures and now proc plays
knights the g8 goes after the f6 pawn
and while you could defend this for
example bishop to d8 then we play rook
h4 and go after the h7 pawn so not
really um you know a good trade-off so
king d6 hun says all right you go
after the the f6 pawn i'm going to play
king to e5 attack your knight then when
you move your knight i'm going to grab
the f5 pawn what process not so fast
rookie four he cuts off the black king
from uh entering the e file and now how
do you play this now the problem is
bishop the d8 no longer is an option
because now knight captures an f6 can be
played and if bishop captures rook here
delivers check king d5 row captures and
this is now again a winning position for
white and and easily winning one so here
rook to f2 uh uh hans continues in the
in the strongest way possible and now
pawn to g4 and here
you can uh really see that proc's
position has improved uh
drastically and that the walls are
starting to close in on hans so king to
c5 we have king to g3 preparing h4 and
g5 rook to a2 and now just pawn to h4
the rook here is doing a wonderful job
guarding the a4 pawn and with the bishop
on b6 there's no way for black to
quickly start advancing his own pass
pawns and create a pass pawn so bishop
to c7 check king to f3 now bishop to e5
uh hoping to get some rook a3 rook the
g3 action in
uh but prague just plays g5 this is the
only way to continue playing for the win
as it creates uh
some squares for the white king to use
to keep pushing so rook a3 check king to
g4 and now rook the g3 check luckily you
have h5 otherwise it would be checkmate
so king to h5 and now we have king to d5
uh leaving us with this spectacular
position that could even be turned into
a small study not a big one but maybe a
small one uh so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only a clean
winning idea for prague while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able uh to
do this congratulations you are a true
master of incredibly tricky end games
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is knight captures on
f6 of course all of you thought about
this but after bishop captures your rook
is hanging so we can't just recapture
here
the move to find is rook to b4 yes again
the b4 square is involved in the the
winning of the game uh but this is
basically what chess is about it's who
uh imp you know who utilizes the b4
square uh most to his advantage will be
the winner of chess game i think the
entire chess game could be summarized
with uh with that idea but okay rook
before here now the bishop still hangs
so you have to move it bishop e5 now
rook captures on b7 and yes white is
down a piece but the pawns are simply
too strong the h7 pawn will fall and
then the three connected pass pawns are
much much stronger than a bishop for
example rook f3 goes after the pawn now
even rook to f7 you don't even allow
black to capture this and now let's say
a5 uh you're just going to play pawn to
f6 if rook to f4 preventing the
king here so you don't lose this just
rook captures on h7 and now the pawns
are too too powerful rook captures here
king to g6 and now the pawns are
marching forward so that's the way to do
it but it is incredibly tricky both of
them are very long time uh proc plays
rook to e2 now he is preparing to
capture and he doesn't want his rook to
be under attack here uh but now uh
uh here he allows f captures on g5 h
captures on g5 and rook to h3 hans finds
the absolute best way to keep fighting
king g4 rook the g3 check king the h4
that's not an h4 king to h4 to prevent a
perpetual
and now rook to g1 we have knights to f6
check and here hans plays king to d6
beautifully played by hans because if
you trade here yes you double proc
spawns but how are you stopping the uh
the past f pawn the king cannot get
across and if you try something like
this uh it doesn't really matter just
rookie seven and this is winning for
white you're just gonna gobble up
everything on the seventh rank uh the
king goes here or even here black clouds
it it's a very easy win so after knight
f6 check king to d6 and now knight to e8
with check
now the king has to go back to keep
defending the bishop king d5 knight f6
check king d6 and not knight to e4 check
we have king to d5 and now uh prague
plays knight to f2 and this is uh very
tricky here to continue fighting you
have to play f6 but proc plays knight to
f2 and now he allows hans an opportunity
to get back into the game and hunts
seizes it rook the g2
now you have a problem bishop g3 check
and what is happening here you are
losing a piece so here rook d2 checked
by prague bishop to d4 now threatening
to win the knight and here prague plays
knight to e4 and the only way to
uh to actually draw this with uh
black is the trait here captures
captures and now play b6 in this
position is a draw if played
if played properly but it looks very
scary with white having uh these pawns
here uh however it was the the way to go
but here rook the g1 was played and now
prague is completely winning but only if
he finds the move that wins the game and
that of course is knight the g3 now you
are uh
blocking the g file you are also
preventing rook to f1 and most
importantly if black plays a silly move
let's say a6 you have an an imminent
threat uh just rook captures on the four
king captures a knight they do check
wins the rook here so that's it king e5
knight captures and yes black will win
this pawn but a5 and that's it it's a
very very easy win for white so after
knight g3 rook the a1 hans again finds
an incredible defensive resource knight
to e2 now the bishop is lost uh but
however king to e5 saying if you capture
with the rook i'm just gonna capture on
f5 and i still have fighting chances but
here knight captures on d4 now defends
the f5 pawn and hans plays not that rook
captures on a4
now the knight cannot move as the king
is also on the fourth rank so now hans
will seemingly win back the piece but
proc says nope uh pawn to f6 and you
don't have a way of capturing because if
you trade uh the pawn is simply too
strong you have seven the pawn queens
and that's it so instead pra hans played
rook to a1 but now knight to f3 with
check king e6 rook to e2 with check king
f7 and here rook the e7 check and he was
in this position on move 64. i always
enjoyed when games end on move 64. uh
that a hans monkey neiman resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here once he moves for example king f8
doesn't really matter where
uh just a knight e5 and now once this
check lands uh that's it you you can
even give up a pawn for this for example
rook chuck king g3 rogue you want your
king f2 you give up the g5 pawn still
this is just winning king goes here you
have to deliver a check king goes here
now a discovery from the rook the queen
delivers check the knight defends the
queen and now it's a very very quick
checkmate nothing
nothing to be done here so really
beautifully done by both of them this
game was uh i mean it was so beautifully
played by both of them uh hans kept
finding incredible resources and the
progress missed a clean win a few times
but it's rapid just of course it will
happen but that only makes the game uh
you know
more interesting and uh you never know
who will win because it's rapid uh
people just blunder stuff uh but yeah
this was truly um uh you know immaculate
play by by both of them uh but yeah uh
very close by hans who uh
still is without a win in this event and
prague now the only player alongside
magnus carlsen with uh
uh three match wins uh uh this event you
okay here's a nice graphic from chess 24
if you guys want to check it out there
you have it uh so magnus and prag uh
only two players with nine points as you
get three points for a win in the match
uh then we have uh with five points
ariana and firija uh who also won his
match yesterday against anishigiri was
really a wild one uh they they drew all
of their for rapid games then i believe
they drew the blizz games and then
alireza won the armageddon duda with
four points liam leia with three
anishigiri with one and hans uh
uh mokheniman with zero points so far so
we'll see what happens everyone of
course is waiting for the clash between
magnus and uh but that will only come
in round five in round four magnus will
be facing uh liam lay and of course uh
will be facing levon arunian so we'll
see if they will be able to
continue pushing with uh you know with
this um
uh you know uh strength of just
crushing everyone and winning every
match uh so yeah uh brilliantly done by
prague uh really looking forward to his
next match as it is against arunian so
anything if he beats arunian and then
goes uh
fight magnus with a perfect score uh i
think the the entire internet will
explode uh but yeah that's the game and
the match hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to jonathan lottie and i would like to
thank brandon ward johan clayson uh
raymond rafael and boontyakpung for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
ftx crypto cup until it finishes thank
you i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day